ban
une semaine marquée par le retour des
cours à la maison pour les écoles
collèges et lycées après l'annnonce de
cette fermeture mercredi 31 mars les
professeurs ont dû s'organiser pour
faire classe il ya des plateformes en
ligne mardi gérald darmanin est allé à
la rencontre de la police nationale au
commissariat de sartrouville
lors de sa visite le ministre de
l'intérieur a annoncé l'arrivée de 16
nouveaux policiers
si le mois de septembre après trois
semaines de blocus le domaine de grignon
a été libéré par les étudiants
d'agroparistech une occupation réalisé
en opposition à la vente du site
historique située à qui leur valent
grignon l'entreprise dunlopillo soutenu
par le département près de 2 millions
d'euros ont été avancées par les
yvelines un budget permettant aux
nouveaux repreneurs fine hadorn de ne
pas payer les murs de sa structure en
création à l'aérodrome de toussus le
noble
un fab lab de l'avion électrique vient
de recevoir une subvention de 250 mille
euros une aide de la région ile de
france pour acquérir deux avions
électriques
enfin depuis le 27 mars le domaine de
dampierre a rouvert ses portes au public
les 90 hectares de jardins sont de
nouveau accessibles pour se balader en
plein air